I'm gonna try to do everything by myself
today it should be fine as long as
everybody does so they are suppose their
form is to get roster that's why I love
you kids can't go emergency PTA meeting
today at five o'clock we see you there
I'll totally get a sitter on a Tuesday
night yeah yeah no Bo I'm actually can
what do I have in the schedule today
you're super late for your marketing
meeting I can't believe I'm gonna be
late for my first soccer practice I'm
sorry okay I'm trying
look I ordered you the bake sale no BPA
no MSG no BHA no BHT
no sesame no soy and of course no nuts
or eggs or milk or butter or salt or
sugar wheat no what's that now I'm so
tired of trying to be the perfect mom
I'm done
you said everything I've ever felt about
my mom but couldn't say there are some
rules now don't punish your kid don't
say no to your kid we all want you team
hard trying to make our kids lives
amazing
magical their lives already are amazing
bad mom's cookin yes and do the cleaning
let's keep the net normal we pay you'd
have to come down the perfect mom are
those store-bought donut host Amy um I'm
going to destroy I say we go punch that
chick right in the tits
I made out with so many women tonight
guys I really like with it is that your
Mambo folks would give one long booze
even if ooh this is my sexy bra looks
like you wrapped an ace bandage around
sorry my cheeks look like an eye mask
you put it in the fridge you got a very
boise the right thing happening right
now remembered something that's not
possible is it okay is it like a picture
in your head and then you think I've
seen this before I just use the word
before which means I'm remembering
something